you know to start with what an amazing
opportunity to kind of recreate beauty
in the Beast I mean it's a great fairy
tale in the original fairy tale from the
18th century and obviously you know you
have this incredible Cocteau version
then you have the Disney version I mean
as many versions you have our version
and we weren't
it wasn't art we didn't set out to
recreate the animation there's a lot of
kind of gaps that were filled in because
if you look at an animation or where an
animation works and you look at
live-action they are so different so it
has to but it had to have the DNA of you
know the original animation and you know
it had the songs it had the characters
but it needed so much kind of filling
out so to speak and it was just an
incredible opportunity to be able to do
that I'm challenging so challenging 18
months worth which I know and I mean for
me it's my favorite fairytale the
original one it just is my favorite and
and then it's a musical so that adds a
different another layer on top that was
the weirdest thing I open it wasn't I
have no so when you say to Bill oh god
build you knows we could do this great
shot and get bill goes okay you've got
three bars and it's kind of like oh no
so that was an interesting kind of
different way of you know you have to
get here to A to B and this amount of
time and things like that so but also I
think one of the biggest challenges from
the animation you know you have these
tiny characters in the massive beast and
you can do all sorts of things with
animation and compression of time and
image and whatever but obviously in our
world
they're real so you have a seven-foot
beast you have a little teacup and you
have an enormous castle and how does the
teacup get ahead of the beast you know
the beast is one step before the Beast
is a hundred steps for Cogsworth you
know so you know there were changes we
suggested for like that the teacup he
used his sorcerer as a skateboard plumet
we changed quite dramatically she was a
french maid in the animation and we made
her more of a kind of dressing table she
was like a makeup yeah so you'd somehow
it's more feminine and we gave her wings
so basically you know when the shots
were moving she could take the shot and
then the other creatures would catch up
and things like that so it was a kind of
challenging it was sort of challenging
overall and then it had these even if it
was just a straight story with all those
different sort of scenarios but then
you're right it's if if chip is that big
and he has been the same shot as the
Beast it's you know so you have to plan
it much more sort of their sort of
environments and where did it go and and
also I think as well you know it's
interesting you know we built everything
we ended up building everything at the
on the stages and the back lot of
Shepperton and in one of the reasons for
that was you know because the even
though we redesigned and made all the
critters we call them the characters yes
and then they were put into CG so they
were animated the Beast was done in CG
now if you follow through and the sets
have been done in CG then you kind of go
hang on me what about this is live
action do you know what I mean so so you
know one of the discs early decisions
was to make to build everything and on
this kind of magnificent scale and so
it's kind of what was great about it was
that we were doing this old-school
Hollywood kind of sets and using all the
crafts and then we were using
cutting-edge technology with the beasts
and the all the characters and how they
worked within the environments so it was
a really fantastic kind of melding of
every skill probably yeah absolutely was
and the other the other big sequence is
the BR gas sequence which really it was
you know set choreography objects yeah
dance I mean it was it was almost like a
film within a film yeah it's so
complicated and everything was shot for
real and then animated like we had a
theater a theater a Broadway lighting
director came in and lit it all yeah we
then filmed it all for real and then it
was animated using that as a kind of key
reference so complicated nothing about
that film was normal but that was what
was great about it was that you were
kind of breaking new ground but yes
still doing something so kind of you
know no
[Music]